bonjour à tous je suis c'est quoi la
technique aujourd'hui nous allons parler
d'un sujet important qu'on entend
souvent dans les médias je vais vous
parler du développement durable alors
c'est quoi le développement durable
c'est en 1987 qu'on a pris conscience de
ce qu'était le développement durable la
ministre norvégienne brundtland indique
qu'il s'agit d'un développement qui
répond aux besoins du présent sans
compromettre la capacité des générations
futures à répondre aux leurs préserver
notre planète devient une nécessité
les hommes ont compris que la terre
possède des ressources naturelles qui
s'amenuise dans le temps comme l'eau le
pétrole et le gaz dégrader
l'environnement avec conséquences pour
le constate avec le changement du climat
pour les sciences naturelles le
développement durable s'explique grâce
au fonctionnement de cycles naturels
dans le premier cycle les plantes créé
de l'oxygène et des nutriments pour les
animaux ils produisent à leur tour de
l'engrais et du dioxyde de carbone pour
nourrir les plantes cette harmonie
parfaite créer une couche de riz tout
cela est possible grâce à la
photosynthèse qui régénère les plantes
qu'il y à aussi au deuxième cycle
géologique qui apporte un équilibre à la
terre c'est celui qui part de l'écorcé
terrestre par le biais d'éruption
volcanique de la matière remonte dont
cette première couche de vie ce qui
régénère les corses de la terre grâce à
des retombées de minéralisation et de la
sédimentation les hommes vivent à
l'intérieur de ces cycles naturels et
créer des sociétés ils doivent être
capables de répondre à leurs besoins
tout en restant dans les limites
écologiques c'est à dire sans pratiquer
une déforestation massive ou en puisant
trop de pétrole dans les sols par
exemple un mode de développement durable
c'est cette préservation des cycles
naturels et comment fait-on seulement
pour répondre à cela on a défini trois
grands piliers qu'il faut respecter le
développement durable doit être à la
fois économiquement efficace socialement
équitable et écologiquement tolérable
regardons cela de plus près le pilier
économique c'est tout ce que nous
produisons et consommons
il faut favoriser à la fois la
croissance l'environnemental et le
social
le pilier social concerne ce qui touche
à l'humain on fait attention aux
conditions de travail à la formation ou
à la santé par exemple enfin le pilier
environnemental c'est tout ce qui touche
à l'environnement comme l'eau les sols
ou encore l'air toute action sur un de
ses piliers a des conséquences sur les
deux autres par exemple lorsqu'un
pétrolier seront verdon l'océan qu'il y
aura une marée noire ce qui touche aux
piliers de l'environnement aussi le
pilier économique sera atteint car les
pêcheurs ne peuvent plus travailler dans
ces eaux de ce fait ils ne peuvent que
gagner d'argent ce qui impacte le pilier
social quels sont les objectifs du
développement durable les objectifs du
développement durable sont de lutter
contre le changement climatique en
préservant la biodiversité la cohésion
sociale entre les gens et les
générations l'épanouissement de tous les
êtres humains et enfin d'encourager la
production et la consommation
concrètement y at il des actions qui
favorisent le développement durable il
faut changer nos habitudes dans les
domaines de la santé des déchets des
transports de la pollution et des
inégalités les ressources naturelles
doivent être utilisés de manière
raisonnable et l' effort doit être
collectif c'est pour cela qu'en 1992 les
dirigeants de la planète se sont réunis
à riom pour le sommet de la terre on a
inventé un plan pour le développement
durable du 21e siècle on parle d'agenda
21 on va agir au niveau des pays des
régions des villes des quartiers et des
collèges
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est le développement durable je vous
dis à bientôt pour un nouvel épisode